right now the functions of displacement
and velocity state the maximum speed ok
so here we go my name I want a
displacement function X and I have a
look at everything that has been
presented to me when I see I about the
origin period at amplitude ok each of
these yeah each of these corresponds to
one of those closets that I mentioned in
lectures I'll read our normal for for
our equation so for example about the
origin right which which Constance is
that refer to each question 20 30 if for
instance I said let's actually keep
quite for me what's the art equation
that's that's on the reference sheet
you'll say x equals everyone's b plus i
think it's a cause NT plus alpha maybe
so like that yes so of these constants
which one does this tell us about it
tells us about be right so I'm going to
say B equals 0 ok because I'm moving
about 0 when I look at this one here
which constant does this tell me about
period how do i change the period or
frequency anesthesia it's about the
coefficient of T right so therefore when
I have a look at this I'll come back
over here period in how do we work out
if i gave you a function like say yeah
15 plus 12 cos 3t plus politics ok so
i'll just put a whole bunch of random
numbers of it how do i work the period
out from that good one ok so i chose the
inside yes if there was a 3t plus
whatever they're ok how am I getting the
period out of that number three do I do
with it what I do the coefficient to
I do 2 pi on three right so 2.3 would in
fact be the period okay but they've
given me the period here I'm trying to
find out what the area is I'm going in
reverse order so I'm going to say it's
supine on em period is 24 does that make
sense and then of course all I need to
do here is make in the subject yes so
I'm going to excuse me multiply it
across / 24 to that puts that go there
this is going to be PI on well yeah ok
good at the 220 meters that's it easier
that's eight and then when you have a
look at the rest of it okay we then get
to make a choice okay you can see here
when T equals 0 x equals 0 so I can
choose to change one of two things here
one of two things firstly just in the
present formats in right now so what I'm
reading off at the moment is 120 cos pi
and 12t plus alpha I don't know what
I'll for easier okay now in order to
make this happen when T equals 0 I'm at
the origin and I'm moving forward so
this is helpful for a month dry yourself
a little drawing right a little a little
graph and have side of the origin and I
just five forwards which is my initial
direction as positive okay so i start at
the origin now i am sorry the origin
Times New York and I move forwards
positive director okay so clearly you
can see to make this into this I can do
one of two things what do you think is
the most obvious thing to do okay i
think the most obvious thing is to not
use collars right but to use side and
that isn't that what we will do in a
second okay but it's important you know
that's on the only thing you can do if i
wanted to keep it as cause i would
change the Alpha right so this is the
phase here so all I have to do is cause
usually starts up here so I'm just going
to which direction
laughs so sorry I'll just working minus
them this is what cause usually looks
like right if you to burn until left to
the right okay so let's think about this
right this let's forget about all the
particular numbers right now let's just
call this one cos x so what I really
want is this graph right so to turn this
crap into this one for example look at
that point then look at that first x
intercept on time in december or it is
an excellent support drop which
direction does that have to move in to
turn into this crap yeah this this is PI
on two right here yes where is that pipe
okay so I've got to go that way so this
would be if I actually have this graph
here I could express this is cos 0 x how
do I shift something to the right mines
owned by this panel too okay so that
would work just fine I would have to
actually work out what would happen with
the particular numbers here but clearly
I don't really want to do this I don't
want to muck around with phase I only
change phase when I have their choice
okay it's much more natural to say okay
if I begin at the origin if you sign if
I begin at an extremity choose cosine
that's the same as way to do this okay
having chosen sign what does that mean
about half are in this case alpha it's 0
that's the whole reason why we chose
sign okay fantastic so we have slowly
die set to the question yes i duplicated
thank you sir why do we need
here for instance I gave you ok let's
think about this remember I said okay
this is cos of X minus power to ya if I
wanted to but sorry beside you because
this is cos of X minus player too or
maybe I should say like 80 minus plan to
ok I don't actually have something which
has a period of 2 pi I actually have
something which is a period of 24 right
so if i change this coefficient let's
give it a simply dinner suppose I change
that to 22 instead of just tea right if
I slap a minus PI on to on this that
hasn't been shifted pi 0 2 radians
anymore how far has that been shifted
how would I be able to tell there's
something I can do a genetically they
helped me see because not believe the
obvious yeah I checked a factor that two
out donut so I would write this ok this
is a very easy trap to fall into because
it looks like well does it matter does
it matter which one of these you do
first is another way that I shift my
phase or whether i change the frequency
and the answer is yes it does matter
right because if that is not pyar to
acting or changing t it's changing to t
so that's why it sort of gets polluted
it gets sort of shared out the two
divisions that it like and um if you
wanted to do it that way yes but I'm
just saying that this is not what you
get this is not the way the equations
have stated right you wouldn't usually
write it in the phone that he will
describe it like this and this is what
you're talking about but simple harmonic
motion is almost there at rest in this
form it's especially this one okay so if
you wanted to do it that way then yeah
that's what you do so you get power to
you there or whatever you want it but
you can see this whole thing just opens
up a can of worms I don't really want to
go down does it be a little bit but
anyway ok I want to avoid lucky around
face all right i'll be ready to just
State this equation now what is this
some displacement equation that we have
determined it's only gift to me from the
beginning
a sign cool that was another good
medical contribution to discussion okay
excellent I've got my displacement
function what am I going to do next yep
excellent so to find the velocity I'm
just going to go with this guy the pilot
12 comes out the front which leaves me
with 10 high side turns into cosine this
guy stays the same okay and you don't
need to do any fancy calculus after this
to state the maximus v you can just look
at that equation and you can tell me
what the maximum speed is it's going to
be 10 pack very good 10 pi what there is
per second frigate yes there's pesky
pies